hi everybody hi welcome
we're here on BuzzFeed live yeah in an
undisclosed location in a hidden bunker
well beneath the city of New York yes
wait city doesn't matter no we're fine
hi everybody hi um we are here to answer
your questions about polyamory and maybe
our polyamorous triad I am 10 I'm a
writer and editor and storyteller and
performer and director sometimes and I'm
Daniel Green wolf and I'm a professional
magician
I also koel co-owned the midsummer
fantasy Renaissance Fair I've Ansonia
Connecticut and I'm also a fire
performer and general stupid person who
does random things for money I'm magic
I'm Vanessa I'm a nurse I've been a
nurse for the past 12 years and I also
perform as Bella green wolf and Daniel's
show so I also do stupid things like eat
fire and jump in boxes and it pierced
with umbrellas umbrella piercing she
puts a plastic bag around my head it's
nothing doesn't die yeah
do you that's why you should always date
a nurse okay we shouldn't please look at
the life - yeah listen we're all gonna
it's like it'll look we're trying to see
very tiny font I think we're trying to
be not okay
wait we do too and that's from we do
have kids we have two daughters they are
seven and eight and they're delightful
insane monsters we love them dearly
they're very happy and do we want to go
into that a little bit about it I'm sure
people are asking a million ask things
so let's welcome back but we do have two
kids yes yes let's see so fast you guys
type so far there's so many of you how
do you guys handle jealousy from Hannah
hi Hannah how are you thank you for
asking that's a big question yeah I
think the big thing we're gonna be
talking about in the next hour you'll be
hearing this word a lot and I apologize
and
apologize it's communication what word
communication ah communication but we
talk about communication a lot because
that's what makes polyamory work now for
those who do not know who are joining us
and have no clue were talking about
polyamory is the idea that you can be in
a romantic relationship with multiple
people whether it's men women any other
gender all in a relationship two people
three people four people whatever
that's polyamorous there's really no one
definition for polyamory it's just not
monogamy exactly and so jealousy is
about communication and talking through
things about jealousy but I think you
guys kind of covered it already
um but it's a normal feeling and it
happens and the most important thing is
to not ignore it because then it'll just
get worse so if you're feeling something
that makes you uncomfortable or that
isn't sitting well with you it's the
best thing to do is to talk about it and
figure out why you're feeling that way
yeah
related we've got a question that comes
in here I want to want to hit what's the
difference between polyamory and
polygamy take it English master alright
I'll go first
so in the most pedantic possible way
it's a definitional difference polygamy
is a legal term that refers to one man
being married to several women and its
opposite is polyandry which would be one
woman married to several men it's
specific to marriage sometimes it has
religious connotations it's primarily a
legal term and of course polyamory is a
term for a type of relationship as Danny
was just eloquently saying that is
non-monogamous in any number of forms
they're very different things in a lot
of different ways the primary difference
there non-monogamy it's a key element to
that having an affair no one's cheating
no one's lying or being sneaky behind
anyone elses back we're communicating a
rule and everything is talked about yeah
do you want it do you want to take the
next I would love to who's it from this
is from Burgermeister honk crawley miss
assistance
and I don't know who that is I love you
so much for doing that to him I love you
too how do you explain to a new partner
that you're polyamorous well I mean it's
the same way that we talk to normal
people about us being polyamorous it's
part of my conversation these beautiful
people are part of my life every day I
mean we've been together now for five
years and we all live together we all
raise our two children together and it's
you know it's part of my conversation
you know this you would know this about
me before we ever went on a first date
you would be well aware of this back
because we don't keep that a secret and
in fact it's unfortunate that there's so
many people who are polyamorous who have
to keep it a secret because yeah the
shame because of the we're lucky in that
way anyway yeah obviously we're not
keeping it a secret no yeah Internet
what's up
mothman's Stan wants to know what is one
thing you wish monogamous people would
stop asking you go to 10 oh you please
you know this is I'd love to hear this
one yes yes you do you think this is
yeah yeah I think you had said it at one
point before but if you wouldn't ask a
heteronormative couple the question then
don't ask it to us um if the question
seems like it might be intrusive then
don't ask it that's specifically about
our sex life how things work in that
kind of thing it's you wouldn't really
to ask a stranger that don't ask us yeah
I mean listen I'm a sideshow freak I get
it I'm carnie trash
I fired my favorite magic trick so close
behind but that part of my life isn't a
sideshow you know we're not a novelty
we're not a novelty this is how we live
our lives and I think it's really
important that you show the same trust
and respect to not just us anybody who's
polyamorous you know if you have
questions you have curiosities there's
ways to ask and actually after you get
to know them I mean we're happy to talk
to folks about it obviously and answer
questions and stuff but sometimes it
helps to open with hey can I ask you a
question
you know and and then you know folks are
more likely to talk so long as you're
not asking
for you know person your information and
weird intimate detailed things internet
you have disappointed me you and I get
sometimes is that is there some kind of
problem marriage and the answer is
absolutely not no wouldn't be able to be
polyamorous if there were we were having
trouble and communication breakdown it
just would not be a good idea to have
relationships with other people so we
should we do the breakdown real quick so
people great do oh god you are so white
I know um no yes I mean I like fishing
ice dropping the stop stop don't you
dare say it don't you dare say drop the
bass did I win anyway so but Ken and
Vanessa are married they're legally
married and have they've been together
for 10 years now 10 years yeah and I
came into the relationship about five
years ago I actually I was married at
the time and my ex-wife is actually part
other was as a it was a quadric
relationship and then my ex-wife and I
we had had problems way before the
relationship started and when you're
polyamorous and you have to communicate
more when you don't communicate it
highlights it so if you're not good at
communicating here's someone who's
keeping some kind of a secret or you're
keeping your feelings locked up it
really shows when you're polyamorous it
comes out in big ways and it becomes
problematic yeah and so polyamory wasn't
the reason that I got divorced but
polyamory helped highlight the problems
that I had in my own relationship and we
tried to work on them but it just didn't
work and so she left the picture and
then it was just the three of us and
it's been three of us now for the last
five years and mr. Roper obviously you
know no nope do you want to talk about
Laura sure yes yes and also I have a
girlfriend that we've been dating for
we've been together for two and a half
years and we love each other she doesn't
live with us she lives on her own and
has her own kids and it's not
romantically involved with the two of
them although they're their close
friends and I think she's watching so
Laura Laura I love you
which actually segues beautifully into
another question
from Whalen Somoza hi Ellen I think I
did that right are you guys planning on
having kids we already do so and if you
if you plan to how would that work if
one of us didn't want kids and I'm gonna
shuffle this off to Buffalo over here
Thank You buffalo Buffalo buffalo no but
I actually didn't want kids
when this all started I never wanted
kids I'm 33 years old
and before these two kids came along and
I came to the lives when they were three
and four and with when we were when we
were three and four they were very young
very young for his age
but no we're three four and they they I
loved them and I just I fell in love
with these kids they're wonderful and
they're amazingly intelligent children
and I realized that these are the kids I
wanted in my life I don't want any more
of my own I have no urge to biologically
spawn and and put this into the universe
so we're all grateful
love you but that's you know and that's
what we're I am and I think that if
you're it's the same thing as if you're
monogamous if one person really wants
kids one person doesn't want kids that
can be a problem that could be something
you that rubs up against I mean just
like anything that would happen in
monogamous relationship can happen in a
polyamorous relationship just or so it's
it it's more important it's always
important in a relationship to like be
communicative to talk to each other and
in a poly relationship it just sort of
if you aren't doing that it can become
much more problematic I think in the
long run if you're not communicating
that stuff well um yeah let's uh let's
we're gonna flip over to fact make sure
we're havin the live feed let's go see
what's on over there and oh my god oh
it's so fast here we go we look downward
and we're so sorry we're so very sorry
all right so uh please pick me all right
flame fusion I'll pick you how does your
relationship work do you each have one
man or one woman I mean we've been
talking a little bit a little bit about
this and then more questions about
things that you shouldn't ask general
humans about but let's do one other
thing too let's make this very clear
where we will go with sexuality is that
I am pansexual I identify as pansexual I
identify as bisexual and I am and have
been out for 25 years give or take yeah
I look very young I also identify as
pansexual and for people who might not
know what that is it's um it's just an
attraction to the person and not
specifically what sex or gender they are
no it doesn't matter to us and and for
Ken he holds on to the bisexual moniker
because he fought for it when he was
because he is the you are the oldest of
the three of us it's true it's true
although I do look the youngest which is
nice sorry I was coughing careful
language yep yeah I was very good fine I
don't look the youngest she does but the
the I keep the the label bisexual even
though I feel the same way about my my
attractiveness to gender as as they do
question taylor ackers wants to know
what does your daughters think about
your guys situation that's kind of
interesting because Daniel came into our
our life when they were so little they
kind of don't know any different and
this they were three and four when when
we when we got together with you so this
is just normal for them to them they've
got a mommy and a daddy and a Danny and
that's who I am and something I don't
know just a general note if you're
polyamorous you're trying to do
something like this and you have
children do yourself a favor don't call
the third person at the fourth person
wherever don't call them on sand uncles
that's weird that's I think that's weird
I don't mean that is very odd and I
don't think that's a good idea I think
that being honest that this is another
relationship we have this is a parent if
that's what you want to do yeah if you
want it to be a parenting even if you
don't want to be a parent if you're
somebody who's polyamorous and you want
them just to be someone you date that's
okay too but just you know be honest
with what the labels are communicate
with your kids talk to them they're very
amazing when it goes that way I've seen
trouble questions on what are our kids
names and while I'm not gonna tell you
what their names are I will say that
they cannot be found on any type of
keychain no
they decided to mess up their children
for life by giving them weird weird
customized pencils that doesn't make you
happy
it's fine Daniel I was always happy with
the customized pencils I would never had
them ever list of the parent wants to
know what's the most complicated thing
about being poly going on BuzzFeed and
answering a Q&A no questions oh yeah
seriously see our calendars Google
Calendar is a wonderful thing but hey I
don't mean to pimp particularly use iPad
whatever your Cal is use a shared
calendar polyamorous that's fine
there's so many different things that we
need to keep track of just everyone
being on the same calendar makes it
really easy yeah and Chrissy Williams
asks is your polyamory exclusive to your
triad or is it open how does that work
for you guys all right Thank You Chrissy
by the way Thank You Chrissy I'll jump
into that one it is not I have a
girlfriend I mentioned that before Laura
so it's not exclusive to our triad we go
on dates occasionally with folks we have
have seen other people on off we're not
exclusive to each other although we
three are the three who live together
yeah and sort of pair it together yeah
so so that's I mean that's the as far as
the exclusivity goes I don't think we're
looking to live with it we also do and
we also you know we also connect with
people separately and we might connect
to people together or they might connect
with someone or I might you know Vanessa
I might connect with somebody or
separately you know it's it's all about
what we feel and and what how we connect
there's a lot of there's a lot of
freedom within the constraints of
polyamory you can build what you want to
build as a relationship however you want
to build it there's a lot of self
autonomy but so long as you're within
the boundaries that you've all have set
up together of communication and honesty
and all the other factors that go into
relationship building yeah so when did
you first learn about polyamory well
back in the Stone Age when I was a boy I
studied on the tablets he did no it
wasn't like he was actually just so
without his lead
he's wonderful though I heard about it a
long time ago and was not actually a big
fan of it back in the day yeah and I
really didn't know much about polyamory
or anything like that until we met you
and yeah and I was gonna say that before
I met them because they were monogamous
before they met me and my ex-wife my
ex-wife and I we were not polyamorous we
were just we were just sex positive
which is a term that we use for being
open sexually and so we would have other
people that we would you know be very
casual play with romantic romance wasn't
involved in that sense and I grew up I'm
second generation Wiccan for those who
might be looking at this and my parents
were Wiccan and so I did I went to a lot
of pagan festivals now my parents were
monogamous their entire lives they loved
each other dearly until my father passed
away and they they loved each other so
strongly that you know that wasn't where
I came from but when I went and did a
lot of these pagan festivals I saw these
people who were polyamorous and all
these people who are you know people in
their 70s who were like polyamorous and
stuff old hippies are awesome they were
my old hippies but the thing about that
was is that I even after seeing people
make it work I still didn't think it was
possible
I was so blind to it because I thought
these are the rules I'm gonna get
jealous this is what it is when the
truth was is that I wasn't going to get
jealous because if I talk about it then
you can work through that kind of
jealousy and so that's how polyamory
works is just by talking about it and
that's how I ended up kind of coming
into it myself this is interesting we're
in the chat Lee ash ji is asking how do
you communicate that's complex a lot our
lives how we don't shut up the hardest
the it's it's hard because you have to
say the things that are uncomfortable
sometimes but also it's great because
you get to get a lot more intimate and
and emotionally tied to your people that
you love by sort of opening yourself up
that way so the trick is to take risks
and open yourself up that's that's how I
think communication works oh is it so
it's cat I can't I just ran by how did
we meet
and the way we the way that we all met
was that
to come up with a lie for this I know
but no the way that was that I was doing
a Renaissance banquet yeah and I was
invited to help out with it because I'd
been in a play with a mutual friend it's
your fault
marci foot by in the chair and they
needed someone with a big loud voice to
come and do a thing so they asked me to
come and help cause you're loud it's
true I am very I'm often loud sorry he
was wearing tights ladies let me tell
you whoo anyways it was February March
very cold so Daniel was I'm seeing and I
was I was sort of loudly yelling and
after that we we sort of hung out a
little bit we went to a party together
and then we all had dinner together and
talked for a long time and just sort of
happened organically so Karl kalsi now
we see what would you define as cheating
this is a great question because people
really have a lot of expectations about
polyamory that you can just do anything
oh no oh no cheating is anything that is
done without consent
cheating is done it with consent of the
partners anything that's done without
conversation
anything you do without being honest
about it and this could say anything I
mean I can talk to people all day long I
can chat with them if I go off and I
meet somebody and I don't tell them and
I go ahead and I make out with them then
I've cheated on you it because I didn't
say anything about it even just a heads
up say hey this is what I want to do you
know and that comes back to
communication she doesn't say it's so on
it doesn't rule out spur the moment
things but but it it enforces honesty
and communication and and Trust you know
it's I can trust that either of them can
go out either together or separately
with a person and then let me know and
that's not cheating you know it's
Bridgette Ness how do you deal with the
negative comments and talk that a
stereotypical of people who don't
understand
polygamy I mean mostly well mostly by
laughing exactly
honey you guys take Larry's hash tag
don't read the comments
seriously I mean sand that it's coming
from a place where people really they
don't get it
so and we had I mean we redid a video
where over 20 21 million people have
seen the video and of us talking about
polyamory and ho ho ho there's there's
some internet but but I will say this
and good on the Internet it is more
positive than negative
I'm a lot of you people out there have
been really supportive and I hope some
of you are watching and listening now
because thank you with all your loves
and kind support and and defending us in
between battle with patron people have
jumped into the fray and almost like do
that we're gonna move here 592 ash asks
we did this one already no no I didn't
do it like oh that's right how do you
deal with privacy between each other for
instance how do you make sure certain
conversations with one partner stays
between you two
oh right and that comes back to
communication I know it's annoying we're
gonna hear a lot but that's it's the
answer to a lot of these questions yeah
seriously I mean there are times when
each of us will confide in one or the
other and meet to complain mostly I
don't think there's anything that I
would say to Daniel or Ken that I would
be like you know don't tell her the
other way I'm Daniel yeah it's very
confusing we look the same articles the
same yeah no look secrets are not useful
largely I mean I have a professional
magician here okay so I understand I lie
for a living and I understand that
listen lying in my real life just it
doesn't help alright so be honest be
open and if you need to keep something
like if we need to keep from him what
his birthday present is you know that is
one thing that's pretty easy right you
know we don't live in like a one-bedroom
apartment where we have
stand next to each other we don't
actually sit like this all the time
we're like where the bodies are buried
she'll be ramen do you guys live
together yes we do we do we've been
living together for three years or four
years four years
I don't do numbers that's fine dude
that's the maths the maths oh here we go
so Sharlene have you ever for any reason
I've been at all embarrassed about your
relationship much love thank you for all
the hearts so you two awesome hearts if
they're anyone who's been embarrassed
it's been her by us I think that's true
we're very embarrassing is gonna do with
Polly yeah at all we're just not very
good people it's true it's true it's
true and then we get to play video games
oh I saw in the in the chat also
somebody asked if we play D&D not nearly
as much as we'd like the answer there
yeah we definitely look like geeks I
played a lot of role-playing games yeah
I want to vampire the masquerade lens
deadlines is great if you haven't played
it yeah so Oh Jake's ruble chicks ruble
so does one feel left out at times
sometimes sure you know there's foam oh
there's a fear of missing out for people
everybody in the internet knows that I
don't know I don't I just know okay so I
thought foam oh you should you should
feel it so you know there's there's that
there's uh I wanted to do that but it's
not really my thing they did a cool date
thing or you know you're just feeling
down people feel down and so you project
that onto under your partners so yeah
sometimes you do feel left out and I
hate to beat the dead horse but the
secret of that is talk about it I think
I think part of it is to just know that
like sometimes you're going to be the
one alone sometimes your partners are
gonna be out with other people or doing
other things and you're gonna be the one
home watching the kids just with nothing
to do and just you have to be okay with
that and realize that that's not all of
the time that's just maybe this time
and I mean it's not aimed at you know
exactly it's not anything personal or
intentionally to leave you out it's just
the way the chips fell that's the hard
part I mean the worst the worst feeling
of that would probably be our Netflix
queue oh my god she's terrible feast
these feasts know these two when we
watched something he wanted to watch it
too that's when this call comes out they
watched things without me and I left I
was out it was yeah you know what no
that was your own fault you know I had
to travel for work yeah whatever
jammy jar is there any advice or a way
to think when being involved or even
invited into a poly relationship those
are two very different that's true I'm
gonna I'm gonna start with the being
invited into part that's a really
personal decision I would say have a lot
of sort of self-reflection and
reflective skills be working on those
things about yourself know who you are
know what makes you feel insecure know
what makes you feel threatened or
jealous because all that stuff is gonna
happen especially when you're entering
into a more established relationship and
you don't want to feel like a lesser
member you know so so when entering into
an established relationship I think
you've got to rely upon yourself a lot
to be able to express your needs and
absorb into a new dynamic and if you if
you are in yeah that's invited if you
are involved in that aside from just
having the you have to be self-assured I
mean that's the same thing with
monogamous relationships you have to be
sure who you are as a person and and
sometimes you can change and you can
change the people with you can change
it's again it cuz I'm talking about and
also being honest with yourself because
so many people aren't honest about who
they are and what they need and if you
aren't honest about that man everything
goes downhill real fast
yeah so self emotional intelligence is
like a really difficult upper-level
skill that you've got you've got to get
into pretty quickly this kind of leads
the next question from smart bunny Melo
would you recommend the people to have a
polyamorous relationship who that's a
personal decision it's not for everybody
so I don't know that I would outwardly
like recommend hey you should try being
poly because it's not a cool trendy
thing to try it's it's a lifestyle it's
it's a it's not something that you can
just turn on and turn off it's it's
something that if you feel like it might
be right for you think about it a little
while maybe a long while and then talk
with whatever existing partners you have
about how they feel about it talk with
find other people in the community we
exist on Facebook we exist on BuzzFeed
live where you can send your questions
into the live chat uh we exist on
YouTube we exist you know people exist
on the Internet find them and ask them
questions a lot most of the poly
community in my experience is really
open to helping your and your biggest my
biggest piece of advice and this is
something I've seen before don't ask non
polyamorous people about polyamory why
why why also don't immediately ask them
about sex please just going back to the
earlier thing yes look Pete what dolts
have sex sometimes not always some
people are ace and so like kids you're
almost forced in there not having sex
sometimes because kids take over your
entire life so like don't start there
yeah that's not the hard part or even
the the most complex part of polyamory
not even just the hardest parts gonna be
talking about it the hardest part is
gonna be being true to yourself the most
interesting parts are the non sex part
absolutely Sydney Evans asks what
happens if to get into a fight like does
the other one try to sort out and how
not if they want to live through it
there's a couple of ways that we go
about this there are times to be of a
mediator yes sort of yeah I mean that's
a nice part is that when you've got
somebody who's in the thick of it with
you who's seen everything go down they
get to be an outside inside perspective
so if two people are fighting and the
third person looks one goes like you're
both acting like Jack wagons they might
call that out and say you're both actor
Jack can you please take a breath real
is that everybody's being an idiot here
and let's talk about what's really going
on is sometimes a useful piece of
information and sometimes it gets a mug
thrown at you but that's not important
it's it's also a growing point where you
can realize what sort of what sort of
things you fight about and how to kind
of tailor that in the future to not get
riled up about the same thing over and
over and then it's I like to try to sort
it out with whoever I'm arguing with
instead of having a third person jump in
because sometimes sometimes it is easier
to just give the two people who are
arguing some space to sort it out
themselves but sometimes it's just a
case-by-case thing it's like everything
else it's such a hard thing to nail down
there's no either/or answer yeah um this
one's gonna be fun
onii-chan thank you for asking this also
with emojis in here somebody give my
best well played how did you'll play how
did your parents react was it like or
and that's very good that was very
Kabuki theater I like thank you thank
you you should sure give it another take
but this thing I should do another take
but I was like give me more on the happy
more than happy to leica there you go
that's good in the hands so sorry my
parents had a lot of questions a lot of
a lot of sort of uh trying to find out
what was going on was everybody okay way
too many people asked are the kids all
right so you're inherit so your parents
were more like the yeah but then they
evolved into I think yeah so so my
parents have had a lot of questions at
first but I think they're pretty
supportive know I'm pretty good about it
also I think my mom is watching so I mom
so uh do you want to go next
um well my parents were we're pretty my
family in general is kind of split on
that some of them are more supportive
and they're in the boat of well if
you're happy then that's what matters
and as long as he's getting hurt and
then yeah their half is like this is
they just don't understand it and are
just generally
I don't get it I don't want to hear
about it and that that's the end so you
just don't want to address it at all
it's like the elephant in the room no
but they have to but we all go to family
functional events and they interact with
us so that's just the way they do things
you know so and then there's my family
my mom is awesome
my mom is the best mom in history of
mom's dance like oh you just made a dead
judge listen my dad if you didn't make a
joke about my dad being dead then trust
me you aren't him a family that's how we
do things but my mother was very very
supportive because she got two new
grandkids to spoil and she was very
happy yeah and my brothers I've got four
brothers and they were all very
supportive of it one of them is very
supportive very supportive
[Music]
he does my little brother Adam if he is
watching hi Vanessa
and rightfully so she's a lovely human
it's true but so my family is really
awesome about it because again we all we
grew up we were already weird I was a
magician of time I was 10 my parents
were Wiccan my brothers are all various
kind of denominations of atheist or
agnostic so they all geeks Oh robust
brownie equal everywhere
look at this does this look like
somebody who really knew about women
growing up now I did though I did
alright this one you go I think you
should you should take it I don't know
if it's difficult you're the expert in
this area I can't thank you wants to
know do you prefer Center brownies or
edge brownies how dare you do you want
to drive this family apart to notice
wrong shoes I need to know no I need to
know
thank you AB dog duh um actually I'm a
center guy I am I like the center of the
- yeah Center brownie I like the edge
ones but not the corners oh there's too
much edge just right
yeah okay you know house like the edge
no you want to do one more yeah all
right all right so yes Haley Plummer we
do share a bed we all sleep in one giant
well not giant but king-size bed we
would love to have the really giant ones
see that I could sleep on more than so
him BuzzFeed Watchers I'm not saying I
want you to fund the big giant bed for
us but fun bed that would be awesome we
don't know where we put it will have to
leave outside but right now we share our
king-size bed and it's fine
yeah it's fine she gets 85 percentage
I'm very very we we both I like to say
we both have plus five two decks
wait that was before bed that was just
when it was so loud in my skull I'm
surprised I'm a black eye right now I've
been really impressed oh okay
no joking this time this is good this is
a good one Ray Murray how do I begin
this with my husband of five years well
step one is your husband interested in
this have you talked to him about
anything related show him this baby show
me show me the other video we were in me
you you say your husband of five years
because we were married for about five
years when we had the conversation about
opening up our marriage we had a great
super awkward conversation it was it was
pretty good yeah it was awkward but I
don't know okay I think I brought it up
and I was nervous about bringing it up
because I didn't want it to seem like I
wasn't interested in him anymore and was
just looking for a way out because that
wasn't the case at all it was a
conversation that you know was important
for me to have and we sort of you know
commented on some friends we knew that
had
and in a more open relationship and and
you know sort of began there and then
talked about well would we ever think
about being open in that way and you
progressed the conversation well let's
learn some more about it and talk about
it and that kind of thing and sometimes
having an example or example out there
to talk about
is a good place to start if you want to
but the most important thing is is if
you both want to do it all right so
we've got to question the chat from
pnina sorry pnina brief Schlesinger's
listen you're - a messenger that's a
good name that's a solid name a good
sturdy name are you guys religious at
all if so how is polyamory compatible
with it then can I go first you go first
no I'm an atheist I don't believe in the
supernatural at all it but so no it
doesn't conflict with my religion at all
philosophically in terms of ethical
philosophy I would actually put it on a
very high ethical choice because it
requires so much honesty and openness
and respect for the other people and
making sure that you don't cause them
hurt so from my end philosophically and
ethically I think that polyamory is a
very ethical choice but no not no no
religion here thanks so as I am
recovering Catholic but I don't identify
specifically with being Catholic anymore
I do consider myself spiritual and I
sort of over the years doing a lot of
research about many different religions
have sort of built my own moral compass
about what I believe is right and wrong
and I think that's sort of how it plays
in because I'm not doing anything wrong
in the sense of I'm not lying I'm not
hurting anyone I'm not being deceitful
so sort of where it fits in for me and
as I mentioned before I am second
generation Wiccan Wiccan Wicca is a
polytheistic religion actually it's a
religion that has multiple deities and
it focuses primarily in nature
I am you know they call us witches that
is a term that is used for us whether
you're male or female or another gender
thing is a warlock exactly what like the
record breaker other things to people
are but and so with that polyamory is
actually very accepting accepted by that
just as the LGBTQIA community is and and
so it's really good for me to have that
path I could have been any religion
thankful my parents they raised us to
look at all the different religions that
there were that we could have just read
the Bible by the way you get a chance
read through it there's some weird stuff
in them Oh crazy
yeah I mean there's some really nice
stories - I appreciate some good stories
there's some great things also the
Psalms are wonderful poems and songs
there's some cool stuff there that's
good reading I love this question hi
Justin thank you for the question
what's positive and constructive ways
that you've used to expose your kids to
the healthy dynamics in polyamory living
our lives basically I mean we try to do
our best because that is one thing a lot
of people are concerned about the kids
and how are they going to be affected in
all of this and it's just they have one
more adult for support one more adult to
love them and just be there and I mean
we all kind of well how about homework
and taking them to their different
after-school activities and they grow up
in a house with so much love that you
know when they see the way that we
interact and the way that we work things
out if there's an argument they see the
way you know we all kind of talk about
things and they see them and we also
took early on I knew that I was
terrified of what I would be as a parent
I was terrified because my father was a
marine in Vietnam my mother as a flower
child so I didn't know what kind of
parent I was going to be was it gonna be
a strict person my in my house you said
yes sir especially if your father gave
you an order so I'm like am I gonna do
that I know that's probably not the best
thing to do what do I do I'm also a
third degree black belt and thanks to
know
a Korean martial art and one of our
daughters takes tang pseudo and so and
she's an orange belt she's doing
amazingly and so she is and and and what
I love about that is that do you get to
I get to learn along with them how to
raise children nobody knows how to do it
right
anybody who says they know what they're
doing is lying it's true I hate all
those books you try not to screw up your
kid too much that's all you can hope for
and we do that by being open and honest
with our communication and loving them
as much as possible and being and being
Stern with them and and and having you
know all that kind of stuff I saw a
question go by in the chat a minute ago
I wanted to say so someone named Daniel
I'm sorry I missed your last name
because it rolled past you said that
your sister is polyamorous and you asked
if you should be worried and I would say
no I would say talk to your sister and
see if your sister's doing okay if your
sisters doing okay then your sister's
doing okay and just be supportive and
and help out you know where she may or
may not need it that's that's what you
need to do and don't think that just
because she's chosen a poly lifestyle
there's anything wrong because it's it's
really not a problem it's a fact the
opposite she's really coming into and
understanding who she is and that works
for her doesn't have to work for you and
that's okay yeah so Wow Raul boga Oh
cheery boga tree boga Raul Raul guys do
on dates figs fruit that's
jokes this is what we do I'm a master so
I amongst all these other things I host
karaoke on a regular basis and so I do
like if I do go on dates a lot of times
the first time someone will meet me I
say come to my karaoke show believe me
he strikes literally out all the time
the reason why I invite them that is
that it's a very it's an open area it's
a safe area for them to come it's a
public space also they might get to
engage me for a little bit and talk to
me but there's no pressure on their part
to have to be facing across me for four
hours you know so I like doing that's
all I care you guys
that's so that that's something that I
do and also go grab a coffee grab food
drinks
I like coffee and book browsing
personally know each other you're a book
browser
yeah coffee and book browsing is a great
date solid choice for me but you know if
the people I'm dating aren't don't want
to do that then it's probably you're not
gonna work if people if someone doesn't
have any books in their home do not have
sex with them that's right thank you mr.
waters that's John Waters john waters
yes how do I bring up the topic of
possibly being polyamorous with my
boyfriend of five years I don't want to
hurt him and make him feel that he's not
enough for me that's your first step
then tell them that say I don't want to
hurt you or make you feel like you're
not enough for me because that's not
what any of this is there's this thing
as a limit to the amount you can love so
tell him that tell him that you love him
and that you also feel loved polyamory
is like anything else and you got a
thing for that way if you have two
parents you love both your parents maybe
you have step parents and you have
regular parents maybe you love all four
of those parents do you have to more
than one child you'll have more than one
child maybe have more than one sibling
you love more than one sibling why is it
so weird to assume that you couldn't
love more than one person romantically
you know and that's where you might be
able to approach it from and when you
talked about that be like I love you I
love you with all that I am and I also
want to experience this other love this
other part of my life I want to
experience as another part of who I am I
want to reach out and I want to make
those connections with other people
because the idea if you think of a think
of thoughts sounds right just the term
like you must love me and no one else oh
yeah like the must that's a thing yeah
you can love me and no one else that's a
choice you gonna make you had
that's perfectly powerful and healthy
choice to make if that's the choice you
want to make but the idea of the one you
get is such a dangerous idea to me
because it it forces you to close off
from feeling things and generally
speaking it's not a great idea to be
like I don't feel these emotions anymore
which connects nicely into this question
which is Carolyn Bechtler that knuckler
I'm sorry Beckler hi Carolyn hi Carolyn
how can you tell that you're in a
healthy relationship well 1 are you
scared
sad or like worried about your
relationship all the time maybe it's
time to have a conversation about it and
and do you do you feel like you can't
talk to your your significant other or
others about something is there
something that I can't bring up to them
or something big I can't bring up to
them because I'm scared of how they'll
react if you're scared of how you're
really the other person will respond
then there's something going on there
and you look at that it's either you
feeling something that that they don't
want to project onto you which is
certainly possible or they're projecting
something onto you which is also
certainly possible so you need to have a
conversation about why you don't feel
like you discuss things and just are you
happy do you feel comfortable do you
feel loved do you feel that you can
communicate easily it's a complex
question with a lot of answers and I
would say talk to friends talk to
friends doctor therapists talk to all
these people these are their ways you
can tell I'm sorry basically your
friends have your friends expressed
concern and Derek Sheridan asks Daniel
and Ken are you also in love with each
other hearts hearts hearts I love you
and we love you we love you there
Chariton thank you thanks for asking yes
yes we do love each other we do that's
that's part of the thing like in this
instance and it's not the same for all
really no no but all three of us love
each other very very much
great question I know I'm trying not to
but I've done literally very very sour
domestic chores distributed says Benja
well-distributed who's in the room where
it needs to be done at the moment the
others get annoyed about it
the garbage Hey actually he takes the
garbage some stamps too also recycling
yeah I do the dishes
thank you I'll take turns doing laundry
I'm usually one to sweep yep it's
because I hate mess I'm usually won't
think organizing and I'm paint the roses
red yeah we all sometimes we put the
lawn because yeah we spent the lawn I do
want a lot I like doing the lawn yes I'm
gonna do the leaves but anyways and
Vanessa will get up in the morning to go
to work and our schedule is very
different so the kids get at the same
time as Vanessa does so one of us will
usually get up and get the kids off to
school it depends on who is easier to
wake up that morning for Vanessa usually
so many times it looks kind of like this
ready ready that's how that works
[Music]
there's no jealousy like at all well ah
there's a lot of different sources for
jealousy most people think about sexual
jealousy I don't actually have a lot of
that I don't feel that in a lot of ways
never have I do sometimes feel tiny
Josie time and I'm envy which is a type
of jealousy I don't value that as a
feeling yes I don't like that I feel it
sometimes so I have to address it by
saying hey I feel like I'm missing this
I feel like I missed out on that or
whatever and we talked about it and and
next time I get tickets to John Mulaney
- that's just the first time Envy is
something that is the most common I
think with polyamory polyamory and with
monogamy before I was ever in a
polyamorous relationship
I used to roleplay every week at my
friend's house with my brothers there
was a bunch of us there and I was out
every Tuesday from 6 p.m. to like 3 a.m.
we were geeks Maximus geeks feminists
and so I do miss it but the thing is is
that I would go out and do that and come
home late and my wife at the time would
get jealous of the fact that I was out
she knew I wasn't hanging
with women she knew I wasn't spending
money she knew I wasn't drinking she I
was doing the most mundane thing
possible because I was not there
she was envious of my time and we talked
about it but it never really got solved
because we talked about it and she put
it aside but that would come back and
and so time envy is something that
exists whether you're polyamorous are
monogamous again it comes back to being
open and honest about how you feel
Zoe Bell do your kids ever have issues
with school other kids because of your
relationship
not yet um no and actually we're very
open about it with their schools there's
you know their school knows because
sometimes one of us might have to pick
them up and so and actually one of our
neighbors kids had kind of Glee
commented to one of our daughters that
oh you have two dads and a mom and she's
like yeah yeah some people have two dads
and and the little girl was like well I
only have one dad and my daughter was
like yeah well some people just have one
dad and that's okay too
so it's kind of they act about the
action normal about it so they don't
really it hasn't I mean kids can be mean
but we haven't really experienced any of
that it's really nice how they're you
know they're they're able to put it very
sometimes to their kid branch just
understand you know the other kids are
just like okay cool and that's it
because kids don't have preconceived
biases I want to I want to say French
ideas asks in in caps what about
Christianity question marks and a bunch
of emojis and I will tell you oh relax -
why don't we just put it this way we're
not Christian yeah that helps yeah I
mean I yeah your your kink is not my
king that's true and you are you enjoy
your Christianity and I hope you like it
hope that works for you right we're
gonna exhume we've got things I want to
there's two questions here's I want to
really jump in that I really loved one
was by Madeleine Potts
Daniel how do you feel about not being
legally bound to the other people in the
relationship this is a really good
question because this is something I'm
gonna fight for my entire life and I'm
never going to win and I know that
polyamory is just now LGBTQ and and are
that part of our culture is just being
to marry one other person less than 10
years I'm seriously I am not confident
that I'm ever gonna be able to marry
them illegally in my lifetime and that
bothers me so much but but I don't take
it on in them I don't take it out on us
I'm upset at the system the system is
flawed cuz religion shouldn't tell you
who you can marry the law shouldn't tell
you who you can marry if they are
consenting adults you should be able to
write out a contra bill to write out a
legal contract between as many people as
you want and that's what it is I know
what their contracts are limited to
one-on-one things I can start a
corporation with anybody I want so like
it's it's a whole nother debate that I
don't think we should go off on but that
is my citement that it's my fight and
that's my advocacy micah westbrook asked
please pick difference between this and
open relationship
oh it's shades of grey i think it's
wrong watch that term now there's a
spectrum there's not it's not that
shades of grey that's garbage I'm not
even gonna talk no no no no sorry I'm
sorry [ __ ] sure yeah the difference is
that polyamory can be closed in that
there can be three people that are in a
relationship together that don't decide
to date other people so it can be closed
there or there can be two couples that
are all polyamorous together and decide
not to date other people so in that can
sense it's closed or you can be you can
be single polyamorous and you're dating
other people in sort of non defined ways
all the time there's a lot of different
ways to be open or closed or any version
of any of that so it's it's one of the
things I like about poly is is it sort
of choose-your-own-adventure
relationship and Jeremy asks how did you
know that you were polyamorous I'm
questioning I didn't know until I got
hit with feelings unexpectedly gingers
can do that to you sorry I'm sorry
Internet oh that's okay we love gingers
let's do magic we're almost like people
oh I didn't really know until I I had an
opportunity to experience it and I think
how would you know if you're polyamorous
or not
I think that's just a lot of
self-reflection and what you feel that
you're capable of what you feel that you
want to do for you and also I mean a
good couple of ideas is that one do you
feel like you are that if you the idea
of being with one person with the rest
of your life just one person does that
excite you or is that something where
you're like I don't know I'm gonna have
to endure that have to endure that or or
if you don't know the answer to that try
some things out yeah Lord those things
for yourself
no one no one gets to define you yeah
you get to make all those decisions for
yourself which leads us to miss labelled
kitty that's adorable
miss labelled kitty is their coming-out
process to your close ones how do you
discuss consent those are two different
questions are very question the first
one so okay I'll jump on this shirt so
coming out is something that I've done a
couple of times and I was quite young I
was in my mid-teens when I came out as
bisexual that was a challenging time for
me and so when we sort of came out as
polyamorous it wasn't that hard for me I
sort of had gone through a tough period
of coming out and so I was able to say
Here I am folks take it or leave it like
it or don't and I don't care what you
have to say about it mostly and that was
that was what I was able to do because
I'd already been through the earlier
experience and had sort of learned to be
thick-skinned about people who aren't
gonna accept what what we decided to do
yeah I just you know started by telling
some close friends that you know I've
had for years I kind of knew that they
would be accepting of it and supportive
even if they didn't necessarily
understand what it was and just it kind
of happened naturally the more people I
told it kind of just got out and then
yeah I mean in the internet being what
it is and us being yeah I was and I'm
I'm also I'm just not quiet I've never
been a quiet person oh I know Ron and
honestly I'm pretty sure most people
assumed I was gay anyway so so this
isn't helping this is no but you know I
just
kind of all at once then polyamorous and
that I'm pansexual and you know and I
just I if you if you accept it as part
of who you are people should accept as
who you are as well
and if they don't what does that say
about them now what does that say about
you
right and speaking of I don't want to
brush past the second part of that
question
oh yeah it's about consent consent is
critical and for me there's a lot of
different ways that people talk about
consent but free it's very very simple
enthusiastic consent means I that they
want it and they've said it clearly in
terms of no matter what it's not just
about sex it's about hugs it's about
doing activities it's about everything
if people want it they you need to ask
and be very clear that they've said
great and that's true in just about
everything you do with other people
they every step of the way yes if they
if every better than yes is please at
any point you stop and something else to
do we don't just consider that for like
our private lives like even our kids
don't have that hug people if they don't
want we don't be like no hug grandma
like we don't do that I mean they he
talks like that usually yeah usually I
look like I'm like a beard so executive
from the 20s all right kids but but we
basically don't try to in fort we try to
enforce that consent matters their body
is their property and we try to do that
whether with anybody that we're with it
Ariba that we connect with consent is
critical necessary yeah the only thing
so courses like this is a good good one
this is tough
I'd like to be in a poly relationship
but I'm terrified that others will leave
me because they like each other more
that I won't be good enough for them do
you have any advice I like your
sunflowers Courtney yeah and I'm gonna
do the the thing that seems like it's
just like patronizing but you're good
enough Courtney I never met you but you
are good enough and if you're with
people that you're good but don't be
with them they weren't good enough for
you those are people that you deserve
people who love you for who you are
equally that you will trust
and that trust you that's important to
remember about yourself and and you can
talk to them honestly and even if the
outcome is not what you were hoping it
was it was going to be that's important
you can the important thing is to know
what's going on not to wonder and stay
in a place where you're not safe and not
trust it and don't feel good if that's
the case if it's the other thing and I
think the other thing is probably more
likely you're probably a great person
who chose great people then you win
because now you get to be honest and
open and out there and you can always
try again remember you're not dead so
you're not done you can always try again
if you're are you a zombie oh sorry
sorry 20 pennies do you have any tips
for handling negative / hateful
reactions to your relationship I mostly
do my best not to feed the trolls and
not to jump in but when I do oh it's fun
but mostly don't mostly ignore them
don't attempt to enjoy yourself in that
way it's a little bit like volcano
surfing yeah you're probably going to
die but if you survive you've had quite
a thrill now that's the question how do
you find other poly people there are
communities there are actually once we
started coming out as being poly we
realized there are so many different
there are Facebook users Facebook groups
and we actually met an amazingly
supportive and lovely group of people
who we consider family now they're
friends of ours and it's just you start
networking and once you start just
Italian classic but as you start meeting
people who are in poly they'll know
people who are poly and it's kind of
just this big network and you'll you'll
find other people
it'll just it just kind of happens now
Yahoo whoo do you guys get misjudged for
your relationship I support it thank you
please pick me just did love all your
hearts you're awesome
yes sometimes we do folks call it out
sort of related to the other thing we
were saying on the Internet there are
plenty of haters and trolls and whatnot
in real life sometimes there are which
is harder but it's far more rare because
people when they get you face to face
it's much harder for them to really look
at you and say the horrible hateful
things that they would put on computer
you think they're anonymous their
computer screens and also you know
Kenna's 6 - I'm a giant 510 with long
red hair who wears a kilt a lot of the
time and I can deadlift the both of them
it's true it's seriously gonna show
right there yeah yeah so we thing is
that I mean don't be shy about don't be
don't be a wilting flower about it you
can be an introvert that's different
yeah be an introvert if you wanna be
must be proud but be proud of you proud
of who you are be confident in who you
are because who you are is pretty great
yeah almost kids do we have we have to
Montana oh and by the way someone asked
us before it ran by the chat
I have not adopted them but I do raise
them and they call me their Danny they
call me Danny
they've occasionally call me da or daddy
and that's fine too but I'm Danny and
that's okay
page em if this is your dream
relationship and thank you go do it
there's people out there find him all
right how is the house set up its mess
mostly yeah that was who was that I
missed their name as we marie e how was
the house set up its mess mostly we have
our sort of bedroom and library yes I've
got a library be jealous other book
nerds we have a good library we have a
solid library it's it's about 50/50
fantasy and magic and theater books
little man oh one oh one two three seven
six are the men awkward with each other
no we're awkward with everything yeah
have you seen we are peak awkward from
Natalie Holly how do you handle money
partner sometimes have combined bank
accounts that's you never held my penny
after penny a bank account he does not
have a bank account with us
but we about the Washington's baby we're
a family and we just we support each
other so when it comes time to pay the
rent we all chip in and pay the rent
when it's time to pay any other bills
utility is that kind of thing we
dissolve chip in grocery shopping some
of the kids whatever we do I do
yeah in my account is far more confusing
because the fact that I've run a
business so when you run a business you
have to have this old kind different
things that taxes and stuff so I am my
own I'm my own human when it comes to
that but that but that's we help each
other out you just got a B yeah since
hear about it honest voice wants to know
bland food or spicy food spicy BAM spicy
I just a bland food guy but I became
spicier yes oh so any deep zebra wants
to know if we have any tips on coming
out as bi all right just do it man oh
yeah Jamie if you feel safe you feel
safe come out to people that you're
saying that you feel safe with to your
friends do it slow you don't have to do
anything big do what makes you
comfortable if that's what you are
comfortable doing don't lie try not to
lie try to be as honest and as confident
as you can it's only my advice so we
communicate and Brown are cute together
oh thanks amber you're cute together too
Oh where's August all of you have
amazing hair thank you appreciate I
appreciate it too yes because you know
what you know what you did you know you
know piano I had mentioned thank you for
talking about this in an open mind I
appreciate a lot a lot of people need
support for this particular subject cuz
this is judged easily we all appreciate
you we appreciate you and we really do
and by the way you know I also noticed
asked to hear my singing voice and I
can't sing because all of that is
licensed music they won't like it but
wait oh no wait they're unlicensed songs
I'll open so we're not singing happy
birthday I have a moral obligation not
to guys kind of kids terrible sorry
Connecticut come to see it I'm around
I'd love to do it oh and OMT
can you go around the circle and see
what you like most about the others
oh that's too hard yeah that takes
[Music]
so okay so what I like most about Ken is
how loving and understanding you are and
I guess this would go for both of you
you know you've you've always been by me
100%
and and I love you I know I'm sorry we
are terrible team compliments so you're
always thinking of how to improve your
show and you're just always chasing
dreams and you never give up on stuff no
song lyrics no song but I absolutely
love that ken is just amazing and
awesome and funny and hilarious and I
love being with him I love spending time
with him and debating with him and
arguing with him and and and just he's a
strong human being and I admire that so
much and about you you're just you're
you come with me and my absurdity and
you enjoy the things that I enjoy and
you've come to love the things I love
and I expect anybody to do that and
you've made me a better person and I
love that about you and I'm gonna go
real quick because we're getting you to
the end of time but Daniel I just love
your creativity and your your brilliance
in how you how you come up with amazing
perspectives on things and and Vanessa I
love your tenderness and vulnerability
and the joy you have no not always
I love you so so I think we're out of
time we are not thank you so much for
watching and and please to hit that
subscribe button subscribe surprised if
I see a video which is its rate of
they're there they know it's there know
you're there it's it's in that we hold
on are you a BuzzFeed video
right button hit the button I hit the
button guys do it do it you'll get more
awesome do you enjoy this and get to
know you can't do with this I know I can
say that okay that was fine yeah and you
know
you